Ich meine, ich werde auf Englisch mit Ihnen sprechen,
ähm,
wir sind wahrscheinlich etwa 15 Jahre davon
entfernt, diesen Zwei-Grad-
Punkt zu erreichen, an dem der Gasgehalt
in der Atmosphäre
einen Anstieg von zwei Grad unvermeidlich machen wird.
Es passiert nicht in 15 Jahren,
weil das System Verzögerungen hat, es
dauert lange
, bis das atmosphärische System reagiert, aber wir haben
ungefähr 15 Jahre,
und wenn wir dumm genug sind
, diese Grenze zu erreichen,
dann ähm, wir fangen an  eine Kettenreaktion,
die bedeuten würde, dass
das arktische Eis schneller schmelzen und
sich in Wasser verwandeln würde, das
mehr reflektiert, mehr Wärme von der Sonne absorbiert, es
reflektiert,
Eis reflektiert die Wärme und Wasser
absorbiert sie, so dass es den
Prozess beschleunigt, es würde bedeuten, dass der
Permafrost  in sibirien und kanada würde
schmelzen und all das co2 und methan
freisetzen, das darunter ist,
es würde bedeuten, dass ein großer teil des
regenwaldes sterben würde, und
wenn die bäume verfallen, würden sie
co2 freisetzen, so dass es eine
kettenreaktion auslösen würde wh  Ich würde meinen, dass
wir drei Grad, vier Grad, fünf
Grad erreichen, das alles würde Jahrhunderte dauern,
aber es würde bedeuten, dass der Planet letzte Woche
in eine Zeit zurückfallen würde, in der
das meiste Leben fast unmöglich ist,
ähm, beide haben recht, und was ich sage, ist
Genau das Gleiche, wenn wir
heute
anfangen und unsere Emissionen jedes Jahr
in einer regelmäßigen
Menge reduzieren, dann können
wir es 30 Jahre lang schaffen, wir können
jedes Jahr 3 pro Jahr reduzieren, und bis 2050 können wir
bei sein  Null, also habe ich das auch gesagt,
aber ich denke, was
nicht klar ist, ist, was das heute tatsächlich bedeutet, dass
die Höhe der Emissionen
an die Menge an Energie gebunden ist, die wir
verbrauchen, die direkt an die
Größe der heutigen Wirtschaft gebunden ist
die beiden gehen absolut parallel, wenn
wir die
Emissionen im nächsten Jahr um drei Prozent reduzieren wollen,
was wir tun müssen, und dann
im nächsten Jahr um drei
Prozent und im nächsten Jahr um drei Prozent, also in drei Jahren
fast 10 Prozent
, was die Wirtschaft bedeutet  10
s sein  Maller, es
sei denn, wir können die Wirtschaft entkoppeln,
was uns bisher nicht gelungen ist, also
bedeutet es tatsächlich, dass
wir unsere Lebensweise sehr radikal ändern müssen
,
wenn wir
dieses Ziel erreichen wollen
Es heißt nicht, dass wir bis 2049 warten können
und dann alles ändern
müssen, um es jetzt zu tun, und
je länger wir warten, desto schlimmer wird es
jetzt werden
[Musik]
Ich möchte nicht sagen, dass sie es getan haben, aber
sie haben es getan, weil  es ist eine tragische
eine tragische geschichte grenzen das wachstum war im
grunde richtig ich meine, ich
sollte klarstellen, dass
die grenzen des wachstums keine prognose war
es war keine vorhersage es war eine reihe
von szenarien die untersuchten was
passieren würde wenn wir uns nicht ändern
und  es hieß, wenn wir uns in
Bezug auf die
Menge der von uns verwendeten Ressourcen oder
das Bevölkerungs- oder Wirtschaftswachstum nicht ändern
würden, würde das System um 2030 bis 2040 zusammenbrechen, aber Sie könnten
diesen Zusammenbruch
lange vorher sehen  und die Folgen
würden  lange danach sichtbar sein,
genau wie jede große Veränderung in der
Geschichte, wenn Sie an
die Französische Revolution oder den Ersten
Weltkrieg denken, Sie konnten sehen, wie sich
das Jahre zuvor aufgebaut hat, und Sie konnten die
Folgen Jahre danach sehen,
und wir können sehen, wie dieser Zusammenbruch passiert
Jetzt ist der Klimawandel das
offensichtlichste Signal dafür, dass das System
auseinanderbricht, aber der Verlust so
vieler Arten
mit Migrationsproblemen, die
Verschmutzung der Ozeane und der
Atmosphäre
sind alles Anzeichen dafür, dass wir
zu stark
aufs Gaspedal treten  und das
Problem des Unterschieds zwischen jetzt und 1972
ist, dass wir 1972 dieses Problem vermeiden konnten,
heute sind wir
mittendrin, und
alles, was wir tun können, ist zu versuchen,
die Folgen einzuschränken, wir können es jetzt nicht stoppen, ähm
Kraft
ist,
wenn ich Vorträge halte, das ist eine
Frage, die immer wieder auftaucht, was kann ich
tun, und ich verstehe diese Frage,
weil ich versuche, alles zu tun
, um das System zu ändern,
die unglückliche Antwort ist, ist es nicht  viel
wenn du vegan wirst wenn du deine flaschen
recycelst wenn du auf ein elektroauto umsteigst
wenn du den zug nimmst anstatt zu fliegen
mahanti macht alex
ich versuche es ich habe versucht diese dinge zu machen
aber ich nehme immer noch viele flüge also
weißt du, zerstöre meine  CO2-Fußabdruck
sehr schnell, aber
selbst wenn alle in europa es täten, dass
alle in europa so nachhaltig
wie möglich leben
würden, würde das die zukunft nicht ändern, denn
wenn man darüber nachdenkt, hat man
drei 400 millionen menschen in europa, aber
man weiß fast  weitere siebeneinhalb
Milliarden
, die das nicht tun, und obwohl
der ökologische Fußabdruck
in der reichen Welt viel höher
ist, wächst er in Ländern wie
Indien und China und Afrika viel schneller
, selbst wenn jeder in der reichen Welt
die Milliarde Menschen in der Welt ist  reiche welt
lebte
so nachhaltig wie möglich unsere unsere
zukunft
bleibt gleich
ausländisch
das ist eine sehr gute frage und für
mich eine sehr interessante veränderung in meinem leben
ich arbeitete in hongkong ich war
s  Während ich viel Zeit damit verbrachte, über
China zu schreiben
und viel Zeit in Südostasien verbrachte, war
dies Mitte der 2000er Jahre, also kurz vor der
Finanzkrise
und ich begann, als ich durch
Länder wie Thailand, Indonesien und
Malaysia reiste, konnte ich
dieses Wirtschaftswachstum sehen  lieferte keinen
hohen Lebensstandard,
sondern brachte die Menschen in eine andere
Art von Armut in den Städten, in denen sie
in die Geldwirtschaft gerieten, aber sie
lebten
oft sehr hart, arbeiteten sehr hart, lebten
in der Stadt, die Umweltverschmutzung nahm zu, ich
konnte  Sehen Sie, da stimmte etwas nicht mit dem,
was wir sagten,
und dann kam die Finanzkrise, die
der Ökonom und natürlich ich vorhergesagt haben,
wir haben diese Finanzkrise vorhergesehen,
und Sie konnten sehen, dass die Folgen
für viele
Menschen schrecklich waren, und so dachte ich
mir  In den letzten 20 Jahren haben wir
ein System
und eine Philosophie gefördert, die auf Wirtschaftswachstum basieren,
das
den meisten Menschen nicht wirklich hilft, es ist nicht
l  Menschen aus der Armut zu befreien,
reduziert nicht die Ungleichheit,
und ich ging zu den Redakteuren des
Economist und sagte: „Schauen Sie, ich denke
,
wir müssen darüber nachdenken, wir müssen darüber
nachdenken, was wir gesagt haben,
und sie waren nicht so begeistert  wie ich das tun sollte
,
beginnen sie jetzt,
einen Prozess zu durchlaufen, der sehr
interessant ist,
ähm, aber ich ging weg und ich schrieb ein
Buch und ich recherchierte ähm
und ii kam zu dem Schluss, dass das, was
wir '  Ich habe gesagt, es war falsch, dass wir
das ändern müssen, dass die
Schweiz einen wunderbaren Ruf
hat, sauber zu sein, mit sauberer Luft
und einem wunderbaren Lebensstandard, und bis
zu einem gewissen Grad lebt jeder hier in einer kleinen
Blase,
aber das stimmt für  viel von europa, aber
was du sagst, ist auch wahr es hat einen sehr
hohen ökologischen fußabdruck es sind vier die
meisten schweizer leben, als ob wir
vier planeten hätten, was zu den
höchsten der welt gehört
und die menschen sind nicht bereit, eine
entscheidung
zu treffen  Verschiebung  sehr leicht, weshalb
dies nicht diese Änderung nicht
über den Markt geschehen kann nicht dadurch geschehen kann
, dass
wir uns alle nach und nach entscheiden,
auf ein anderes System
umzusteigen, weil das rentabel und
wirtschaftlich sinnvoll ist, wir müssen
wir müssen regulieren wir haben  um
die Menschen zu ermutigen, ihre Lebensweise durch Vorschriften zu ändern,
leider, aber das müssen
wir tun  17.
oder 18. Jahrhundert Wir müssen zu einem
Lebensstandard zurückkehren, der vielleicht eher
den 1970er Jahren entspricht
, das sind die 1960er Jahre, in denen
nicht so viele Menschen Autos haben. Wir haben
keine billigen
Flüge. Wir haben keine Ferien auf den
Seychellen  Wenn wir nicht
annähernd so viel konsumieren und wegwerfen wie heute
, können wir einen sehr guten
Lebensstandard haben. Wir müssen nicht,
wie Sie wissen, leben, als ob wir in Höhlen wären,
aber wir müssen ändern, was wir sind
tun und wir müssen es radikal ändern
, um mehr Wachstum zu haben e  Jedes Jahr bedeutet,
dass wir mehr produzieren müssen,
offensichtlich müssen wir mehr verkaufen, und das
bedeutet, dass wir mehr produzieren müssen, also müssen wir, um
mehr zu produzieren,
mehr Ressourcen ausgraben, die wir ausgraben müssen,
was auch immer es ist,
die Metalle oder die
Veränderung  Öl in Plastik, was immer wir herstellen
müssen, wir müssen jedes Jahr mehr produzieren.
Das ist offensichtlich, dass Dienstleistungen
weniger Ressourcen benötigen, aber sie erfordern immer noch
etwas. Sie müssen immer noch einen
Computer haben,
Sie müssen immer noch eine Internetverbindung haben
, und all das erfordert
etwas  produziert, also ist
es nicht so, ich meine, wenn Sie Haare schneiden, verbrauchen
Sie nicht viele Ressourcen
, aber es gibt nicht viele, viele Unternehmen,
und der größte Teil unserer heutigen Wirtschaft basiert immer noch
auf dem Durchsatz von Ressourcen,
und um diese Waren herzustellen, benötigen wir
Energie  Es ist ganz einfach, dass wir Strom
oder irgendeine Form von Energie produzieren müssen, und 80 Prozent
dieser Energie
stammt aus fossilen Brennstoffen 80
und obwohl wir viel in
erneuerbare Energien investiert
haben  Der weitaus größte Teil davon wird
nach Angaben der Industrie für fossile Brennstoffe in
20 Jahren immer noch aus fossiler Energie stammen,
so so, weil 80 davon stammen, was
das CO2 erzeugt, das Methan
erzeugt, das Lachgas erzeugt,
und das dann die globale Erwärmung erzeugt, so
der Vorstoß  Immer mehr Wachstum
ist die direkte Ursache des Klimawandels
, das ist absolut richtig. ii wir haben
das,
ich meine, wir werden später darüber reden,
warum wir uns nicht ändern, aber ein Teil davon ist,
weil wir
diese Weltanschauung in uns haben
darüber, wie es funktioniert, darüber, wie wir uns
entwickeln, was Fortschritt bedeutet,
was Glück bedeutet, und das meiste davon ist
falsch,
es ist sehr schwierig, Ihnen klar zu machen, dass es
so groß ist, aber die Vorstellung, dass
Wirtschaftswachstum notwendig ist, ist
grundlegend falsch, für das
wir gelebt haben  Jahrhunderte ohne
Wirtschaftswachstum und
wir hatten nicht unbedingt einen sehr hohen
Lebensstandard, aber das ist eine
andere Frage, die
wir haben könnten, wir müssen den Lebensstandard trennen
und Wachstum
, aber wenn Sie darüber nachdenken, haben
wir 200 Jahre industrielle Entwicklung hinter uns,
und die Kluft zwischen der reichen und
der armen Welt ist heute
größer als 1820 und die Kluft zwischen
Arm und Reich
in Europa  ist heute größer als
, also vor dem Ersten Weltkrieg, also hat all
dieses Wirtschaftswachstum
die Ungleichheit nicht verringert, es hat
die Kluft zwischen Arm und Reich nicht verringert, es hat sie
vergrößert, denn
wie Thomas Picketty vor
ein paar Jahren in seinem berühmten Buch sagte  kapital des 21.
jahrhunderts
das ganze system belohnt die reichen das
geld fließt nach oben es fließt nicht
in die taschen der armen es fließt
nach oben
in die taschen der reichen
und wir glauben das gegenteil weil
uns das gegenteil erzählt wird
und dasselbe gilt für die Arbeitslosigkeit,
wenn Sie sich die reiche Welt seit 1990 ansehen,
wir hatten einige der schnellsten
Wachstumsraten
in der Geschichte der Menschheit, und doch ist die
Arbeitslosigkeit gestiegen,
die Welt ist besser geworden, ja, wir hatten
wirtschaftliche Gr  owth
ja, die beiden sind nicht unbedingt
miteinander verbunden,
es hängt davon ab, welchen Zeitraum Sie betrachten,
wenn er über den Rückgang der
Arbeitslosigkeit oder über den Rückgang der
Ungleichheit spricht
Lücke in der Welt
der Reichen Sie kommen aus der OECD Sie kommen aus dem
Klub der reichen Länder,
das sind also offizielle Zahlen.
Es ist sicherlich wahr, dass es nach dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg
bis Ende der 1970er Jahre eine
Zeit
starken Wirtschaftswachstums gab  Es gab eine
Zeit des Wohlstands
, in der der Lebensstandard durch die Ungleichheit verbessert wurde.
Arbeitsplätze wurden geschaffen, die nur
wegen des Wachstums entstanden,
und ich würde behaupten, dass Wachstum
da war, aber das war
fast ein Nebenprodukt. Wir
haben nach dem Krieg von einer niedrigen Basis aus begonnen, also
mussten wir  Wiederaufbau, der viel Wachstum schuf,
aber auch den Lebensstandard verbesserte,
aber der Hauptunterschied war, dass es in dieser
Zeit auch einen großen Einfluss der
Regierung
gab  Es waren die Anfänge
des Wohlfahrtsstaates die Schaffung von
Gesundheitssystemen die Sozialsysteme die
Hilfe bei Arbeitslosigkeit die
Bereitstellung von Renten
all das geschah in dieser Zeit,
weil der Staat
jetzt, Ende der 1970er Jahre, eine viel größere Rolle spielte
Neoliberale begannen, mehr zu
sagen,
und dann begann Ende der 1980er Jahre das
einzige konkurrierende System, das kommunistische
System in der Sowjetunion,
zusammenzubrechen,
und so haben wir seitdem eine viel
stärkere
Form der neoliberalen Ökonomie gesehen, und das
drängt
Dinge zurück in die andere Richtung und
so schreibt die Ungleichheit wieder,
es ist
fremd,
ich meine, hier gibt es einige
interessante Fragen, eine brauchen wir
überhaupt Wachstum,
zweitens, gibt es technologische
Lösungen oder ist grünes Wachstum eine Lösung,
wenn man das BIP der Reichen nimmt  Welt
und teile sie durch die Bevölkerung, es gibt
leicht genug Reichtum und Einkommen und Arbeit
für alle, die
es nicht braucht, wir könnten wachsen, wenn es
einfach die wäre  Das Problem ist, dass es schlecht
aufgeteilt ist,
dass es ungleich verteilt ist, also gibt
es arme Leute, die reiche Leute sind, aber
wenn Sie das System nehmen
und es einfach durch die Bevölkerung teilen könnten,
könnten alle perfekt leben,
also brauchen Sie dieses Wachstum nicht, also das ist das
Erste  alles eine Fantasie,
aber die andere Fantasie ist, dass wir
dieses Problem innerhalb des bestehenden
Systems lösen können. Dieser ganze Drang nach grünem
Wachstum
für nachhaltiges Wirtschaften ist
völliger Unsinn  Die Leute denken, dass sie
sich nicht so sehr ändern müssen, dass
wir einen Weg finden können, das System nur ein
wenig zu optimieren, und alles wird gut,
aber das gesamte System hängt von Wachstum ab,
hängt von Wachstum und Ressourcen ab, und es
hängt davon ab
, Profit zu machen  jede
Phase des Prozesses, der die Ungleichheit erhöht,
aber das Ganze wird
von diesem Bedürfnis angetrieben, mehr zu wachsen,
und selbst wenn Sie es grün nennen, tun Sie es
immer noch  das gleiche müssen Sie
immer noch all die Energie haben,
die die Emissionen erzeugt, die
wir brauchen, um von dieser
Idee wegzukommen
, dass es eine Lösung innerhalb des
Systems gibt, es gibt keine marktbasierte
Lösung dafür, weil es keinen Gewinn
bringt, den Klimawandel gut zu beheben, ist
es nicht  Ich meine,
lasst uns zuerst das Energieproblem angehen. Ja, es
hängt davon ab, wie wir die Energie erzeugen,
äh, aber zuallererst wird es
lange dauern, bis wir
alles
auf Sonne, Wind oder Kernkraft umgestellt haben, was auch immer
nicht ist  werden diese Emissionen
verursachen, die eine Menge Geld kosten werden, während
die Ölindustrie immer noch
jedes Jahr investiert.
Letztes Jahr hatten wir 70 Gigawatt neue
fossile Energie und
40 Gigawatt davon waren Kohle, also erhöhen wir
immer noch
die Menge an Investitionen in
alte Energie und das macht uns das
Problem noch
schlimmer, aber zweitens, selbst
wenn wir ein vollständig erneuerbares Energiesystem haben
,
wie macht man die Solarmodule, wie macht
man die Windmühlen
?  Du, wenn du die Autos herstellst, musst du
die Batterien drin haben, und
sie sind aus ziemlich unangenehmen Metallen,
die in begrenzten Vorräten sind,
du hast immer noch die Fabriken,
die die Energie benötigen, es
gibt immer noch hundert Möglichkeiten, die wir
nutzen  Ressourcen und Energie,
die wir langfristig nicht leisten können, wir
müssen einen Weg finden, uns davon zu entwöhnen.
Okay, jetzt hat diese Sicherstellung
[der Musik]
ein langsames Ja gebracht, ich meine, ich weiß, das ist eine
schockierende
Sache, wenn die Leute es wollen
übers wochenende nach barcelona verreisen oder für
100 franken wandern und das können sie heute machen
aber es macht keinen sinn für die
umwelt
ii wenn du sagst du weisst wir haben ich
will das system ändern
ja und nein ii will  ein anderes
Wirtschaftssystem sehen,
aber jetzt ist nicht die Zeit, darüber nachzudenken,
wie ein besseres Wirtschaftssystem aussieht,
jetzt ist nicht die Zeit, über ein
nachhaltiges Wirtschaftssystem
nachzudenken, das vielleicht Jahrzehnte oder Generationen brauchen wird, um
zu entstehen, wir brauchen so etwas
wie ein neues en  Erleichterung
, unser gesamtes Sozialsystem zu überdenken,
in der Zwischenzeit müssen wir aufhören,
die Atmosphäre zu verschmutzen,
aufhören, den Planeten zu schädigen, und das
bedeutet, wir müssen aufhören, die Dinge
zu tun, die den Schaden anrichten, den wir haben müssen,
aufhören
, Kohle zu verbrennen, wir müssen aufhören  Mit Öl
müssen wir so schnell wie möglich auf Gas verzichten.
Jetzt haben
wir vielleicht 20 Jahre, aber je schneller wir es
tun,
desto einfacher wird es und wir haben
immer noch eine sehr hohe Chance,
uns in Schwierigkeiten zu bringen, aber das ist nicht nur
das, was wir haben  Wir müssen aufhören, Autos zu fahren,
wir müssen aufhören, zu fliegen, wir müssen
aufhören, Schiffe zu benutzen,
all diese Dinge verursachen das
Problem, jetzt werden sich alle das ansehen
und gehen,
das ist Wahnsinn, und
je länger wir warten, desto
radikaler muss es sein
aber es ist ein bisschen so, als ob Sie wissen, dass ein
Arzt zu Ihnen sagt, Sie wissen, dass Sie
Lungenkrebs haben,
und und und Sie sollten mit dem Rauchen aufhören, und
Sie sagen, nun, ich kann das nicht,
es ist zu unbequem, Sie müssen aufhören,
und es ist dasselbe mit  das müssen wir
stoppen und wir müssen einen Weg finden, dies zu ermöglichen
,
und deshalb müssen wir den Menschen, die
von der Autoindustrie abhängig sind
oder in der Luftfahrtindustrie arbeiten
, einen Weg finden, diesen Menschen zu helfen,
damit sie es nicht persönlich tun  leiden, aber
dass sie mit dem aufhören, was sie tun,
sage ich nicht, dass das einfach ist. Ich weiß, dass
dies sehr schwierig ist
wie eine Kriegsmentalität,
äh, es ist, als müssten
wir in sehr kurzer Zeit eine große Veränderung in unserer Wirtschaft vornehmen,
weil es ein Notfall ist, also über
Nordstrom, genau,
genau, es ist wie ein
Notizständer,
wir müssen sogar eine Menge Änderungen vornehmen
obwohl das schwierig
ist, wenn man bedenkt, was wir
über diesen
IPCC-Bericht gehört haben: 35
Reduzierung der Emissionen bis 2030 80
bis 2040. Das bedeutet, dass wir aufhören müssen, das zu
tun, was wir tun, und ich
verstehe, dass das schwierig ist, wenn wir es tun
jetzt können wir es
dir k  jetzt drei prozent pro jahr drei
prozent klingt überschaubar
aber es sind immer noch 35 prozent weniger autos
35 prozent weniger flüge 35 weniger schiffe
in 10 jahren das ist eine gewaltige veränderung aber
aber die wahl geht weiter wie wir sind
oder oder ihr stellt die ganze
zukunft in frage  menschheit,
ich meine, es ist eine so große frage, dass es
dich oder deine kinder nicht betreffen wird,
ich meine, deine kinder, deine enkel
werden ein ziemlich unangenehmes leben haben
, aber aber es bedeutet, dass innerhalb von jahrzehnten
ich meine, wenn du nur in der mitte
um die herumschaust
Ähm Mittelmeer Ich meine, Sie sehen
20 oder 30 Jahre
bevor es unmöglich sein wird, dort zu leben.
Ich meine, es wird kein Wasser geben, Sie
werden nicht in der Lage sein, Getreide anzubauen,
Sie wissen, dass die Menschen
aus Griechenland wegziehen müssen
teile von süditalien von
südportugal davon ist nicht
nur in bangladesch das wird
uns in europa betreffen
ausländisch
[musik]
ich bedauere, dass wir das geschrieben haben,
weil äh
wir es so einen großen backl geschaffen hat  Asche, äh,
besonders in der deutschsprachigen
Welt,
was wir sagen wollten und was
ich immer noch für wichtig halte, ist, dass
Sie wissen, dass ich gesagt habe, dass ich vorhin gesagt habe, dass die
Hauptursache des
Klimawandels das Wirtschaftssystem ist,
die andere Hauptursache die Bevölkerung,
wenn ich  wurde 1960 geboren es gab drei
milliarden menschen auf der welt heute wir nähern uns
acht milliarden wir kommen 80 millionen pro jahr
hinzu wir kommen jedes jahr ein weiteres deutschland hinzu
und die meisten menschen ich meine drei
drei milliarden menschen heute sind sehr
jung
ich meine ihre zukunft  Der ökologische Fußabdruck
nimmt immer noch zu
und und wir diskutieren dieses Thema nicht,
dieses Thema wird ständig unter
den Teppich gekehrt,
und wir denken auch, dass es ein Problem
für die arme Welt ist,
es sind die Chinesen, die Inder, es sind die Afrikaner, sie sind die
Menschen, die es müssen  Hören Sie auf, Kinder zu haben,
und was Jürgen und ich sagen wollten,
ist, lasst uns dieses Thema diskutieren
und uns bewusst sein, dass wir in der reichen
Welt
auch Teil des Problems sind, weil unsere
Kinder Kinder haben  eine viel viel größere
ökologische auswirkung als ein in afrika geborenes kind,
weil jeder an dieser 80
prämie festhält jeder an diesem geld festhält und
das dann die bevölkerung
ablenkt so ein schwieriges thema, weil die
leute deswegen so emotional werden,
weil es vielleicht das ist  die
persönlichste aller freiheiten
sie glauben, dass sie
ein besonderes recht haben äh kinder zu haben
und das verstehe ich und und ich denke
ihr wisst wann wann
prozent frau veröffentlicht wurde es war
auch die zeit als die große auswanderungswelle
nach deutschland kam
und  die leute in deutschland sagten
sich, was es bedeutet,
deutsch zu sein, was passiert, wenn unsere bevölkerung
schrumpft und die migration
der migranten zunimmt, was es bedeutet,
zu sein, und es hat einen sehr
wunden nerv getroffen, und ich denke, das hat es auch
sehr emotional gemacht,
iiii bedauern  dass wir diese Nummer
darauf setzen
, aber ich denke immer noch, dass dies ein Problem ist, das eine
der Hauptursachen
für unsere Probleme ist, und wir diskutieren
nicht  Es ist und
Sie wissen, dass die Natur das Problem für uns lösen wird,
wenn wir nicht eine
Lösung
[Musik]
für das Medium finden.
Ich habe vorhin gesagt
,
dass wir auf unterschiedliche Weise darüber nachdenken müssen,
wenn wir  Wir
näherten uns einer Kriegssituation
und das erfordert einen anderen Ansatz.
Eines der Probleme, die wir
in den letzten 10 Jahren immer wieder hatten,
ist, dass ich Donald Trumps gefälschte
Nachrichten verwenden möchte, aber wir hatten viele Leute, die
berichteten, dass der Klimawandel es nicht ist
wirklich ein Problem und
dass das alles von den einzelnen
Klimaskeptikern erfunden wird, genau
das wird alles von den anderen
Linkssozialisten erfunden, die nicht wirklich verstehen,
wie die Welt funktionieren sollte,
und und und sie haben ein größeres
Problem geschaffen,
weil viele  Die Leute sind wirklich verwirrt
darüber, was passiert und was sich ändern muss,
also haben die Medien
in diesem Prozess eine negative Rolle gespielt,
und wir brauchen die Medien, um in diesem Punkt zu helfen
, es ist ein bisschen so, als würden wir es tun  o laufen
[Musik]
Menschen helfen, die Notwendigkeit von
Veränderungen zu verstehen
und und im Kommunikationsbereich in
der Werbebranche
und in der Medienproduktion kennen Sie beide
Seiten des Arguments, das die
Menschen verwirrt,
ist an dieser Stelle nicht sehr hilfreich,
in gewissem Maße nicht  Matter II
meine,
es ist wirklich egal, was es kostet,
denn weil Geld nur eine
Erfindung ist,
meine ich, es sind nur Zahlen auf
Computern, Geld existiert eigentlich nicht,
ich meine, es ist nur etwas, das wir
erfunden haben, und wir regen uns sehr
darüber auf  und und als das bankensystem
2008 in die krise geriet,
meine ich, auch heute
noch drucken die Zentralbanken auf der ganzen welt immer noch
geld
und nicht in den usa, aber sicherlich in
europa und japan und in
england drucken sie immer noch geld,
um es zu versuchen  die Wirtschaft am Laufen halten den Bankensektor am Laufen halten
sie haben Billionen Dollar und Billionen Franken gemalt,
damit sie Geld drucken können, wenn sie
den Bankensektor retten wollen, den wir drucken können
Geld, um den Planeten zu retten,
also macht das Geld-Ding, aber was würde
es kosten, okay, also was würde es kosten
, das Energiesystem
in den nächsten 20 Jahren
umzubauen, könnte kosten, könnte vielleicht 10 bis 15 des BIP kosten, es ist keine große Menge  Geld,
wenn man es über 15-20 Jahre
aufteilt, jedes Jahr ein Prozent mehr, woher
unser ein Prozent kommt, bevor
wir beginnen können, die Wirtschaft in
die richtige Richtung zu lenken, ohne eine
riesige Menge Geld auszugeben,
aber das zählt nicht  für all die
Ressourcen, die im Boden
verbleiben, die sogenannten Stranded Assets, all das Öl, das nicht ausgegraben werden kann, die Kohle, die dort bleiben muss, das Gas
, damit sich all diese Unternehmen
in große finanzielle Schwierigkeiten
bringen  für die Entschädigung
, die
für all die Menschen geleistet werden muss, die ihre
Arbeitsplätze abbauen, berücksichtigt sie nicht all
die Menschen in der Autoindustrie oder der
Luftfahrtindustrie, die das
alles zusammen hätten, also wissen Sie, dass Sie es hier
sehen  wahrscheinlich  Wie
Sie wissen, sind 30 oder 40 Prozent des Welt-BIP
plus eine Verringerung des Welt-
BIP ein enormer Kostenfaktor, aber wir können es
über 20 Jahre verteilen, wenn wir 10 Jahre warten,
müssen wir es viel schneller
als einen Monat machen
[Musik]
okay  Wir haben keine globale
Regierung
, um dies einzubringen. Ich möchte noch einmal sagen, dass
ich an keiner Stelle
gesagt habe, dass dies einfach ist. Ich sage, dass dies der einzige Weg ist
, den ich sehen kann,
und Sie wissen es, um ehrlich zu sein  die hoffnung ist
sehr gering, dass dies passieren wird. ich bin
nicht sehr optimistisch, wohin wir
gehen,
aber es ist ziemlich klar, dass wir keine
globale regierung
haben, weil wir die un nicht in der rolle haben, dass
ich viel mit ihnen arbeite  un
sie fühlen sich so machtlos wie die meisten von
uns
also wo fängt man an wo fängt man bei den
menschen an die
das problem am besten verstehen jetzt ist
der deutschsprachige raum meiner erfahrung nach gut
ausgebildet
ist umweltbewusst hat eine geschichte
des gemeinsamen handelns zum guten
das ist ein guter punkt um damit anzufangen
die germans be germany austria
Teile von Teilen der Schweiz, vielleicht
Skandinavien, diese Länder verstehen
die Probleme
und haben möglicherweise die Fähigkeit
, anderen ein Beispiel zu geben.
Ich sage China,
weil xi jinping sich
ausdrücklich zum Ziel gesetzt hat, eine ökologische
Zivilisation zu werden,
jetzt, wo die Chinesen die Welt sind  größte
Umweltverschmutzer,
aber sie investieren auch mehr in
erneuerbare Energien
als der Rest der Welt
zusammengenommen Potenzial oder absolut,
und sie haben letztes Jahr mehr investiert als
Amerika in 50 Jahren
, also verursachen die Chinesen vielleicht eine
Menge Umweltverschmutzung, aber sie.  Sie nehmen
Änderungen sehr ernst,
sie sehen das Problem besser als die meisten anderen,
und weil
sie sich keine Sorgen um die Demokratie machen müssen
, können sie
ihre Änderungen viel einfacher umsetzen,
also
wissen Sie, und dann wissen Sie, dass Sie den Papst erwähnt haben,
der Papst Franziskus war
besonders
äh offen gegen die Probleme
des Wirtschaftssystems
und die ganze äh la dato Seezeitung,
die vor ein paar Jahren produziert wurde  Vorher
war es unglaublich genau, worüber es
gesprochen hat über den Klimawandel
das Militär das deutsche Militär das
amerikanische Militär sie verstehen
unglaublich gut die Gefahr die Sicherheitsgefahr
des Klimawandels die Migrationsrisiken
und so fängt man an das Justizsystem das
Bildungssystem zu sehen  eine
Gruppe von Menschen,
eine sehr seltsame Koalition von
Organisationen und Ländern
, die das Problem tatsächlich verstehen und
etwas dagegen tun wollen,
und wenn Sie die chinesische und die
katholische Kirche und die
Teile Europas hinzufügen, kommen Sie auf zwei
drei Milliarden  leute die
sich jetzt wirklich ändern wollen
meine idee ist vielleicht wenn sie
ein vorbild machen dann folgen vielleicht die anderen
aber das ist wahrscheinlich die beste
chance die wir gerade haben
abella bekommt keinen moment das fremdgefühl
das
er absolut recht hat  und das ist
eines der größten probleme, das die meisten
leute im sommer in der schweiz gelesen haben.
ich meine,
es ist fantastisch oder wenn ja  Wenn du nach
Österreich und Hoita gehst
, reden sie über ein herrliches Wetter zum Sonnenbaden,
und so dass die Leute nicht erkennen, dass zwei
Grad den Planeten tatsächlich
10 Millionen Jahre zurückversetzen
, scheint es, als wäre es eine kleine Änderung, die sie
nicht verstehen, dass
das Wetter, das wir sehen, ist  heute liegt nicht
an den Emissionen, die wir
vor
einer Woche produziert haben, sondern an den Emissionen, die wir vor
15 Jahren produziert haben,
und was in den nächsten 15 Jahren passieren wird,
ist, dass es schlimmer wird, egal was wir tun
,
und und und das ist das Risiko  wenn wir
alle
absolut klar sind wenn wir alle
so ein feuer in griechenland oder den sturm in
hongkong oder den schlimmsten sturm aller zeiten vor
ein paar wochen
erleben wenn wir alle das erlebt haben
und uns allen absolut klar ist, dass
es in leiden zu spät ist  Schlaganfall ist
einer der Hauptgründe, warum wir uns
nicht ändern, weil wir
die sogenannten Rückkopplungsschleifen
in der Atmosphäre nicht verstehen,
ich meine die Atmosphäre, die die Wissenschaftler tun,
aber die Tatsache, dass wir vor 15
Jahren w gemacht haben  Was heute passiert, wenn Sie
daran denken, einen
Topf auf den Herd zu stellen und einen Topf Wasser zum Kochen zu bringen
, haben Sie das Gas voll aufgedreht, aber es
dauert immer noch so lange, bis
die Energie zum Erhitzen des Wassers erzeugt ist, das
genau genau genau genau festgelegt wurde, und
darin besteht das Risiko  dieses aber aber aber
es gibt eine Zeitverzögerung zwischen dem, was passiert,
was wir tun
und was und der Wirkung, und das ist es, was die
Leute jetzt nicht verstehen.
Es ist extrem schwierig, die
Leute dazu zu bringen, das zu verstehen, und es ist
daher extrem schwierig,
diese Änderung vorzunehmen,
und deshalb  Warum
mein Vorschlag ist,
dass wir diejenigen zusammenbringen, die verstehen, dass
Sie wissen, was mich hoffnungsvoll macht, ist, dass
es
jeden Tag mehr Menschen gibt, die das Risiko sehen
, die vor ein paar Wochen
aus Südkorea vom IPCC berichten
, das eine riesige Menge geschaffen hat  der
Medienberichterstattung und so verstehen mehr Menschen
das Risiko, dass wir uns in die
richtige Richtung bewegen, aber wir bewegen uns immer noch
zu langsam, leider
diese ganze Idee, dass wir die Welt verändern können
dass die Verbraucher
nur Unsinn sind oder dass wir die
Ursache des Problems sind, es ist auch falsch, dass
Sie keine Entscheidungen getroffen haben, Kohlekraftwerke zu bauen
, und jetzt sterben sie
dort, und deshalb haben Sie
vorhin von einer Art
internationalem Gericht gesprochen  Gerechtigkeit
Es gibt Menschen, die dafür verantwortlich sind
Es gibt Menschen, die
Entscheidungen getroffen haben Politiker oder Menschen in der
Öl-, Kohle- und Gasindustrie, die
in diese investiert haben,
weil sie wussten, dass dieses Problem
passieren würde,
die Ölindustrie kennt den
Klimawandel seit mehr als 20 Jahren  Jahre
und sie haben weiterhin darin investiert
, jetzt
müssen sie meiner Meinung
nach
für das Problem zur Rechenschaft gezogen werden, und sie sind die
Lösung. Ich meine, sie hören auf, was
sie tun,
was Sie und ich tun, wird nichts ändern,
was wir brauchen  die Quelle zu stoppen und
das bedeutet, dass wir diese Industrien davon abhalten müssen
, das ist eine gute Frage, wissen Sie,
ich wache an manchen Tagen auf und denke,
oh, es ist zu spät, es ist zu spät, ich kann nicht
Mache alles und an manchen Tagen wache ich auf und
denke, okay, ich muss weitermachen.
Das ist ehrlich gesagt sehr schwierig,
nicht nur für mich, sondern auch für viele Mitglieder des Club of
Rome, die
seit langem in diesem Bereich arbeiten und
sich emotional verbunden fühlen  An alle,
die das Richtige für den
Planeten und die Menschheit tun wollen,
und ich meine, nachdem Grens Grenzen des
Wachstums veröffentlicht wurden, ich meine,
die Autoren wurden verspottet, sie wurden
ausgelacht, und doch hatten sie recht,
es ist an manchen Tagen äußerst schwierig,
optimistisch zu sein
Aber wie Sie wissen, hätte Margaret Thatcher
vielleicht
anders gesagt, dass es keine
Alternative gibt. Wir müssen einen Weg finden
, dieses Problem zu lösen. Wir müssen
vorankommen,
und ich halte nichts von dieser Idee
, die wir haben  eine positive Erzählung zu haben,
eine optimistische Art,
das ist eine Sache, es ist
eine sehr ähm, ich denke, eine sehr amerikanische Art
, über Dinge nachzudenken, dass
wir ein Happy Hollywood-Ende
haben müssen, wir müssen realistisch sein, das
Leben in den nächsten 20 Jahren
schwierig wird es nicht einfach wird es
nicht sein
der Lebensstandard wird nicht
höher die Löhne werden nicht höher
wir werden einige sehr
schwierige Entscheidungen treffen müssen und das Klima wird
beängstigender
und  und so zu tun, als würde alles
ein flauschiges Rosa und eine flauschige Zukunft werden,
ist nicht hilfreich, denn dann
kannst du nur Enttäuschung aufbauen
realistisch,
ähm
, das ist die Stimme der
englischsprachigen Welt,
äh, wissen Sie, wir gehen nicht in den Krieg und sagen,
wie können wir Profit machen,
und das ist, was er tut, wie können wir daraus
Profit machen,
wenn ich eine Rede halte, wenn  jeder meiner
kollegen hält eine rede in den vereinigten
staaten, die
einzige möglichkeit, dass irgendjemand zuhört, ist, wenn
sie einen geschäftsfall präsentieren,
hier ist dies, hier ist die antwort, und sie
können gewinn machen, sonst
hört ihnen niemand zu,
und das ist es, was er tut, ich meine ja,
technologie  kann helfen
ja wir können Gewinn machen ja wir können wir
können Sie wissen wir können wir können
erneuerbare Energien bauen und und einiges davon
aber Sie wissen, dass es keinen Gewinn
bringt, eine Stadt zu verlegen, es bringt keinen Gewinn
, höhere Deiche zu bauen,
es bringt keinen Gewinn  Beim Umgang mit dem
Insektenbefall oder der Armut
, die
sich über ganz Afrika ausbreiten wird, gibt
es hundert Möglichkeiten, wie
Sie wissen, dass dies keinen
Gewinn bringen wird, es gibt zwei Prozent
oder vielleicht das, also konzentrieren wir uns auf die
98,
und das wissen Sie  sehr schön, aber
es wird nicht lange dauern, bis Systeme funktionieren.
ii war, äh, als
ich jünger war, war ich immer
von der Erleuchtung fasziniert. Ich bin
Schotte, und die schottische Erleuchtung
war eine sehr mächtige
Kraft, und ich sah das
als eine Periode an  Wo ich wirklich leben wollte,
wollte ich Teil dieses
Denkprozesses darüber sein,
was bedeutet, was bedeutet Eigentum, was
bedeutet Freiheit, was bedeutet Fortschritt
,
und jetzt ist mir klar, dass ich das eigentlich
nicht will  Beschreiben Sie das als eine falsche
Wendung, aber viele
der Konsequenzen, die wir heute für das
Wirtschaftssystem haben,
sind unsere Sicht auf die Natur, unsere Werte
in Bezug auf Eigentum und Preis, und
viele davon stammen aus dieser Zeit,
also hat es uns hierher gebracht und und es ist
kein guter platz es führt uns jetzt in eine schlechte
richtung also denke ich wir müssen
unsere werte überdenken was bedeutet was
bedeutet fortschritt
es geht nicht um wirtschaftswachstum es geht nicht um eine steigerung des
bip es geht sicher um die
verbesserung des menschlichen wohlfahrts es geht um ein
besseres leben es geht  darum,
mehr Entdeckungen zu machen,
es geht um die Verbesserung der Lebenserwartung und der
Lebensqualität. ii. Stellen Sie sich vor, es geht darum
, langfristig zu denken, es geht darum, im
Gleichgewicht mit der Natur
zu leben
Genossenschaftsgesellschaft
ähm, also denke ich, dass wir
viele unserer Grundwerte noch einmal überprüfen müssen.
Demokratie
wir müssen die demokratie haben
einer von jurgen jurgen
vanderz sagt gerne, dass sich
die menschen in europa irgendwann in den nächsten 20 jahren fragen werden
, warum china in 50 jahren
schneller gewachsen ist und
in 50 jahren mehr für mehr menschen erreicht hat
als europa und  aber es ist nicht demokratisch
und jemand wird sich fragen,
vielleicht ist die Demokratie Teil einer
sozialistischen Familie aus Schottland. Ich glaube
an die Stimme der Menschen, aber ich
verstehe auch, dass es dauern wird,
wenn wir dieses
Klimaproblem angehen wollen, indem alle zustimmen
Das demokratische System ist zu lange so im Moment,
und ich sage das nicht stolz, dass das
demokratische System ein Hindernis
für Veränderungen ist, weil wir uns alle einig sein müssen, dass
wir
diesen Konsens in der gesamten Gesellschaft haben müssen,
und wenn die Leute das nicht
verstehen  Problem
, das sehr schwer zu erreichen ist, also
denke ich, dass wir darüber nachdenken müssen,
woher
Sie wissen, dass ich nicht vorschlage, dass wir eine
Diktatur haben,
wir brauchen eine Gruppe von Menschen, die
fast wie sind  technokraten
zu bis zu um die notwendigen änderungen vorzunehmen
das ist das interessante
aber wir müssen irgendwo anfangen und
und aber das entfernt sich von der
frage die frage ist, dass
wir viele unserer grundwerte überdenken müssen
das wird  Nehmen Sie
die Erleuchtung in viele Jahrzehnte und es
wird viele Jahrzehnte dauern, weshalb ich
sage, dass es zwei Schritte gibt. Der Prozess
ist erstens,
den Schaden zu stoppen, und zweitens, darüber
nachzudenken, wie man damit umgeht
, um
gut zu bestätigen i  meine, wenn du zu emmanuel
kant zurückgehst oder zu john stuart mill,
sie haben freiheit völlig anders definiert.
ich meine, freiheit
ist das recht zu sagen und zu tun was du willst,
solange es andere nicht verletzt
, es geht um freiheit  des Denkens
und des Ausdrucks
und der Umsetzung von Ideen geht es nicht darum
, so egoistisch wie möglich zu sein
und sich nicht um
Ihre Konsequenzen für die Gesellschaft zu kümmern.
Wir haben uns selbst in eine Situation gebracht,
in der wir
einer von denen sind  Probleme, die den
Wandel stoppen, ist etwas, das als
historischer Block bezeichnet wird, der
auf die
Philosophie von Antonio Gramcis aus den 1930er Jahren zurückgeht
Ideengeflecht,
und vieles davon ist grundlegend
falsch oder im Grunde die Ursache der
Probleme, die wir jetzt
haben, und dieses Ideengeflecht zu enträtseln, wird Zeit brauchen, und
es wird auch dauern, herauszufinden,
was sie stattdessen sein
sollten  Zeit, und ich sage nicht
, dass das einfach ist,
wir haben nichts, aber das drin, das
würde in jedes Haus gehen.
Ich habe einige der
Grundprinzipien in diesem Buch aufgelistet. Ich meine, dass
sie
sehr seltsam wären, sie erscheinen
den meisten sehr seltsam  Menschen Ich meine, es bedeutet
kein
kontinuierliches Wachstum des Ressourcenverbrauchs, es
bedeutet,
es bedeutet Einschränkungen für die Bevölkerung,
die menschliche Bevölkerung,
es bedeutet, im Gleichgewicht mit der Natur zu leben,
es bedeutet, die Wirtschaft nicht zu messen
In Bezug auf das BIP oder
vielleicht kein Geldsystem
bedeutet
dies eine so radikale Veränderung in der Art und Weise,
wie wir denken, es ist fast so, als würden wir
zu den Ökonomien zurückkehren, die
in der Römerzeit oder vor Jahrhunderten existierten,
basierend auf völlig anderen  Werte
zu haben, um ein System zu haben, das
über Jahrhunderte nachhaltig sein wird,
erfordert einen völlig anderen Ansatz,
ja, aber zuerst müssen wir den
Klimawandel stoppen, das ist das Wichtigste,
was wir tun müssen,
was wir können, und die
Politiker aufzuwecken,
was Sie können  als Einzelpersonen
sicherstellen, dass die Menschen verstehen
, anderen helfen, zu verstehen, wie
dringend dieses Problem ist
, anderen helfen, den Politikern zu
verstehen helfen, dass
sie handeln müssen, dass sie im Interesse der Menschheit handeln müssen,
nicht im Interesse der großen
Konzerne, was ist was  Viele von
ihnen machen heute
[Musik],
wir haben unseren scheinbaren Einfluss
an die großen
Firmen weitergegeben, und das ist ein großer Teil des
Problems  Das große Problem, das wir haben, ist, wie
wir diese Botschaft rüberbringen. Ich meine,
Sie wissen, dass Al Gore seinen Film vor ein paar
Jahren hatte.
Er hatte nachfolgende Filme. Wir hatten die
Grenzen des Wachstums
Wir versuchen seit mehr als 50 Jahren, den Menschen verständlich zu machen, wie groß und wie dringend das Problem ist, und wir sind gescheitert, wissen Sie,
die Umweltbewegung ist
gescheitert, weil
wir nichts erreicht haben, was wir
erreicht haben  keine änderung jetzt, wo
ich dieses buch geschrieben habe, ich denke, ein teil
des grundes für das scheitern ist das timing,
das timing muss so sein, dass die leute
offen zuhören und wenn man sieht,
dass in griechenland 92 menschen verbrannt werden
oder sie sehen  etwas wie ein
sturm, der durch new york zieht, oder du siehst so
etwas wie das baumsterben in
südportugal
, die leute fangen an, es aufzuwecken, das
timing ist besser
, aber die leute hören immer noch nicht
genug zu
und manchmal
du